[Music]
bigquery is a fully managed data
warehouse that provides incredibly fast
sql analytics over large data sets
bigquery provides more than 100 data
sets publicly available to analyze
covering a variety of data types from
historical weather to taxi trips taken
in new york city
we try to offer utility data sets such
as the u.s census data so that customers
can join these data without needing to
import them
while these data sets are being used in
vital decision making across enterprises
they are also a great place to get
started with analyzing data in bigquery
get started by navigating to the google
cloud console at
console.cloud.google.com
if you are new to google cloud and
bigquery use the video linked in the
description below to set up a new
project in the bigquery sandbox no
credit card is required
open the navigation window and select
marketplace
in the left-hand menu click to filter by
data sets
each tile represents a public data set
for example the american community
survey is an ongoing survey that
collects social
economic housing and demographic data by
surveying more than three and a half
million u.s households annually
in addition to being used in
governmental funding decisions private
businesses also find this data useful in
their own strategic decision making
clicking on the tile will provide you
more detail on the data set
including a description of the data set
sample queries
and metadata showing information such as
when the data set was last
updated and if there is a regular update
frequency
to access the dataset click the view
dataset button
this opens a new console window and
brings you to the data set in the
bigquery web ui
you can see each of the tables available
within the data set
in fact you can scroll through the other
public data sets in the program here as
well
back to the acs data set click on a
table
and you will see the schema or columns
available in that table
along with the table details including
the size and number of rows
and a preview of the first few rows of
data click query table and a template
will appear in the query editor which
already references the selected table
if you'd rather start with one of the
sample queries you can also click the
run this query button from the details
page you are looking at earlier
let's look at this one how is king
county rent cost as a share of median
income changed between 2011 and 2017
in the query editor click run
and in just a few seconds you have a
table showing how the rent as a
percentage of median income has changed
for each zip code in the county
looking to analyze data without writing
sql just highlight the table you wish to
analyze in the left-hand nav
click export and choose explore and data
studio google's data visualization tool
bigquery charges for storage and offers
pay-as-you-go on-demand pricing
or flat rate pricing for predictability
when querying data
you can also take advantage of the free
tier option to quickly get started
use the bigquery sandbox to stay safely
within the free tier
more info on how to get started in the
bigquery sandbox linked in the
description below
happy analyzing
[Music]